Well,
like most people that don't live on the
south side of Chicago or in Illinois,
they're really.
The first time that I ever heard of him
was when he was running for Senate and
we were looking at the New Yorker for
interesting Senate,
Congressional and State House races to
write about in addition to the
presidential race,
and somebody mentioned this guy,
Barack Obama,
that he was interesting and he was quite
possibly going to win and it was a state
world kinds of bizarre things were
happening in that Senate race.
Remember the first real great event was
his big democratic opponent.
Blair hall disappeared from the race
because his divorce records were opened
up and that wasn't an edifying spectacle
at all.
And then of course there's this big
speech.
So Obama comes on the scene in 2004,
unless you're a real Illinois political
nuts and you know,
he gave that speech.
I went to the Boston convention in the
summer of 2004 and he was pretty damn
good.
He was even better on television.
He had really learned that,
that fine art of giving a speech to a
big crowd and yet not over projecting so
that it would come off as shouting on
television.
So he was really developing these
talents.
Um,
2004,
but I gotta tell Ya,
there's no way in the world I thought he
would be a presidential candidate in
2008,
much less a successful one.
Well,
we wanted to put out an issue of the New
Yorker just after the election was
pretty clear that Obama was going to win
and they were going to be four or five
big pieces.
David Grann,
Ryan Lizza,
um,
were among the riders in that issue.
I want it to write about race.
And I'd written a fair amount about race
in my time as a journalist.
And Ryan was interested in other things.
Grand was going to write about Mccain
and I'd written a biography of Muhammad
Ali.
I knew my way around,
a little bit on the south side of
Chicago because that was part of the Ali
geography and politics.
And I sort of took that on and I was
intrigued by the speech that Obama gave
in March 2007 just after he announced
for the presidency at in Selma,
Alabama at the commemoration of the
great,
you know,
bloody Sunday events in the march from
Selma to Montgomery.
And he declared,
first of all,
he gave his great thanks to what he
called the Moses Generation,
the Moses generation being the civil
rights generation,
the generation that gave so much
opportunity to people that were coming
down the line that succeeded on the
civil rights act,
on voting rights,
on breaking open access to institutions
like institutions of higher learning
that Obama benefited from after all,
he went to nothing but elite
institutions,
Pentaho's school,
Occidental,
Columbia,
Harvard law school.
This would not have been possible
without the Moses generation.
And even that went,
which went for it.
And then he declares himself the head of
the Joshua Generation,
his generation,
people in their thirties,
forties,
fifties,
who benefited from these elders.
And he does this incredibly a ballsy
thing.
He says,
I'm the leader of the Joshua Generation.
And he goes right after the African
American vote,
because if you remember Hillary Clinton,
the Clintons thought that they had a
pretty good purchase on the African
American vote because of their,
um,
long associations and Obama was
challenging that.
Well,
first of all,
in order to get the Democratic
nomination for the presidency,
the African American vote is a very big
deal.
You have to pursue that vote and you
pursue it hard,
not Iowa of course,
where there aren't very many,
but elsewhere down the line,
Obama could not assume that vote was
his.
Remember who knew who Barack Obama was
at that point.
Very few people,
really insiders,
people who had watched one speech from
some time ago,
he had to really pursue it.
The Clintons didn't assume that they
would win it,
but they had a real historical purchase
on it.
They had associations with certainly
with lots and lots of black leaders from
around the country.
After all,
he had been president for eight years.
They had done a lot of time in black
churches and black groups and there was
a real relationship there.
There were a lot of loyalties and a lot
of members of the civil rights
generation,
uh,
and people of that generation in media
and in show business and in business,
people who are going to be donating
money had long associations with the
Clintons.
Um,
somebody like Vernon Jordan,
people who ran bet,
so obama couldn't just jump in and by
dint of is being African American
assumed he was going to get that vote.
He had to go out and win it.
He goes to Iowa,
which is a white state,
and he won the Iowa caucuses running on
the kind of appeal that you had seen in
previous years.
Like Gary Hart.
In other words,
he was appealing to kind of well
educated,
liberal leaning whites,
party regulars,
and they came out in droves from him
because of the level of associate of
organization in the state.
He wins the Iowa primary and that starts
to give people around the country ideas.
Suddenly he's on a much more equal
footing with Hillary Clinton.
And so black folks in places like South
Carolina,
which is a crucial primary state,
said,
ah,
I see.
And that,
you know,
there was a chain reaction occurs now
that's not to say that black people
voted for Barack Obama and South
Carolina because they had some kind of
permission from white people,
but black folks didn't want to be voting
for a symbolic candidate that had
happened before.
They'd been many symbolic candidates.
And there are even been Jesse Jackson in
84 and 88.
There is no Barack Obama,
by the way,
without Jesse Jackson.
Jesse Jackson role is false.
Did an enormous historical good by
breaking down the barriers toward the
political imagination of having a
successful African American presidential
candidate.
Well,
it's,
it's worthwhile to kind of fact check
the strangeness of Barack Obama's
Beginnings in,
in,
in racial,
ethnic,
and identity terms.
He grows up with the exception of a
sojourn in Indonesia,
in Hawaii.
And if you've ever been to Hawaii,
first of all,
this,
this feeling of great,
almost isolation in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean.
And it's a place that prides itself on,
um,
on variation on,
on a multiculturalism.
People using that word long before it
was fashionable on the,
uh,
on the mainland.
And yet it's a multiculturalism lacking
one very striking thing in American
terms,
black folks and most of the black
population in Hawaii,
the little that there is,
is on military basis and Obama goes to
one of the fanciest schools in the
country of this,
this private school called [inaudible]
Ho in Honolulu,
which looks like Exeter or andover,
if you imagined it right near the beach.
Lockers outside,
people walking around in this shoe.
I mean,
it's just fantastically.
It looks like it looks like a highschool
created by,
you know,
a Netflix of cello or something,
a beach fantasy of what high school
could be.
And he goes there and it's diverse in
some sense.
There's lots of Asian kids of all kinds.
Um,
all the various stripes that you see in
Hawaii,
but just a couple of black kids.
And when he goes home at night,
it's two white grandparents.
So how does he learn how to be what he
sees in the mirror.
He pursues it by watching things on
television,
listening to certain records,
reading certain books.
He goes out and assertively goes after
it and he does it then geographically by
going to Los Angeles,
but he's kind of in Pasadena and that's
not good enough for him.
He goes to Columbia,
which is of course close to Harlem and
finally ones up on the south side of
Chicago and there he's finally able to
find community community,
a sense of purpose,
a sense of idealism,
a church black church specifically,
and he really begins to solve these
identity questions there.
By the time he gets to Harvard law
school,
these things are resolved for him,
but when you go into public life,
it's a question of how people see you.
So he's got to struggle with these
questions all over again.
When he does things like run for
Congress or for state senate.